some penalty for that offense if you
plead guilty or found guilty is up to
death and or imprisonment for life do
you understand yes
shocking new details in the brutal
killings of four Idaho college students
the suspect Brian coburger making his
first court appearance in Moscow to face
four first-degree murder charges
prosecutors releasing a stunning 19-page
affidavit with Excuse me affidavit which
lays out their case coburger's DNA was
found on a knife sheath left next to one
of the victims bodies police then
matched that DNA to trash from the
suspect's family home in Pennsylvania
the documents also reveal that one of
the surviving roommates woke up to the
sound of crying on the night of the
murders and froze in fear after
witnessing a masked man wearing all
black walk past her and toward a sliding
glass door she then went back into her
room and locked the door okay the
affidavit is 19 Pages judge I know that
you had it earlier today you looked
through the whole thing what stood out
to you well there's the first thing that
stood out to me is that I I applaud the
the police work in this case I think for
the longest time everyone assumed that
we were dealing with small town USA who
hadn't had a homicide since 2015 and
they were all the Keystone Cops what is
clear from this affidavit is that on
November 13th they actually had the
state police go with them onto the scene
the forensic collectors so they had all
their ducks in a row and the FBI is on
the case almost immediately so that that
is the thing that gives me a great deal
of confidence number one is the fact
that we had an eyewitness who actually
saw the murderer heard the crying
um and the murderer the question is why
didn't he kill uh and what do we refer
to her as DM I think
um she described him as being tall
having bushy eyebrows and of course he
was tall athletic build bushy eyebrows
she said five ten or taller he's six
feet tall the the most interesting part
of it is of course the car and everyone
talks about the cell phone and that
there were 12 times before the actual
murder where the cell phone was in the
vicinity but that is a tower recognizing
it we don't know how wide the space is
that that Tower reflects the pinging of
the cell phone but his taking off from
the crime scene was caught on a camera
then what you see is law enforcement at
its best we think it's an Elantra what
year is it and then they send it to the
FBI and they code through with it but
the the cop that impresses me is the one
on page six and I'm not going to take a
lot of time was he says that given the
direction that the Elantra was going but
426 the morning after the morning of the
murders he assumed it might be going
into the state of Washington and that's
a hunch that's just a cops hunch and
sure enough once they started working
with other law enforcement they realized
that you know they had pictures of
Elantra is and then as it goes on his
fingerprint or some forensic we're not
sure if it's his fingerprint is on the
button to the sheath of the night they
match it to the father's DNA in the
garbage can now you can rest assured
they've got his actual DNA with the DNA
on that which makes it one in a trillion
uh Greg that's a good point about the
the police were taking a little bit of a
beating on some people but it turns out
that they knew what they were doing yeah
they had it they had it they couldn't
they couldn't share what they knew for
obvious reasons you know in the Oscars
when somebody wins an award but they're
not there and then somebody accepts the
award yeah I would like to accept this
award for Jessica tarloff who yesterday
called this right she called this about
the traffic stop she said that those
were delivered they were deliberately
tracking him and pulling him over and
and and and to get whatever information
they were getting and she was poo-pooed
but I would like to accept the award and
say that I actually called it I'm the
one who called it yes the traffic stop
was so amazing when the suspect
interrupts his dad like right when he
brings up where they were coming from
and he's like look so pissed at his dad
Dad shut up don't tell them wherever I'm
coming from you ruin everything yeah now
I'm going to jail for a life but I do
think I I think it really is a testament
to life how well the law enforcement
people have kept this under wraps did
everything right and they were going to
look Vindicated this guy looks like he's
guilty the other thing is is that they
kept things so quiet like nothing leaked
they were very good about it including
the information about the roommate who
saw the eyewitness she never said
anything and that is actually pretty
remarkable yes yeah she saw the guy's
bushy eyebrows that makes me a little
nervous yeah I thought of Alibi so I'm
covered there I'm with the judge this
was a great job by the FBI we criticized
the FBI a lot on this show this is what
they should be doing and they stay out
of politics look how good they are and
again the locals did an excellent job
collaborating with the FBI they had all
their ducks in a row and they had a nice
communication strategy which was to lull
this guy into a false sense of
complacency and so he kind of sticks his
neck out and they got him interesting
little tidbits from the affidavit too he
applied for an internship with the
Pullman Police Department you add that
to the fact that he studies criminology
and he was like crowdsourcing things is
on Reddit and also he he the warrant for
the phone shows him all around the crime
scene that night turns it off during the
murder and then turns it back on and
they go back earlier in the fall and he
was stalking the victims and casing the
apartment since August since August and
it was Target cops had exactly pulled
his pulled him over twice in the fall in
the white Elantra
this guy he might think he's smart but
he's an idiot right Harold last comment
I I agree with everything I think people
who criticize local police and local law
enforcement uh should should applaud
this and those who have been critical of
the FBI should applaud this finally I
just the motive here I'm still this is
one of the more unbelievable things as I
look at this this young guy he looks
like someone you see on an airplane a
restaurant and any building you're going
to obviously in a classroom can you
imagine those who've been in class with
him for years studying criminology and
you see this so it's it's it's a
obviously to tragedy and Humanity that
it's lost in the families that have been
hurt but I look at this and it just you
just wonder what are we becoming who
this God is you know you wouldn't draw
his face up and draw his picture up and
draw his resume up as a person that
would do these things I'm not talking
about his racial makeup just him as a
person how he looks obviously as you
know these things about him he said oh
that guy looks like he's crazy but if
you didn't you look at him I'm sure
people in his class in the classroom
with them say you know what this guy is
that this guy's a terrible he could be a
killer so I'm curious to hear more about
the motive here yeah the motive here I
mean I don't know if you remember
Leopold and lo a friend of mine a low a
friend of mine's prosecutor mentioned it
it was a Thrill Kill they were criminal
justice majors at the University of
Chicago they picked a young child and
killed him to commit the perfect crime
it was called The Throne kill Leopold
and low evil minologies hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not not get it anywhere else